strong strong peace it's a free peace  and it's a strong peace  i feel quite sorry for prague who had to  have his exam today yeah i'm like why  couldn't his teachers just let him off  for one day yes as well right you know  the biggest chess talent in india maybe  just you know can take the exams next  week yeah pretty good excuse you know  playing against the world number two  chess player in one of the biggest  events of his life  so far at least um yeah do you find it  difficult id to bounce back from defeats  um  yeah yeah because i started questioning  everything about myself when i lose  chest not just my chest and the playing  skills  like my whole life yeah  so it's very hard i take losses very  very hard it seems to be something about  chess with you know losses even having  you question your life choices  and we do have a result pragnanda he  does lose the first game and the final  in chessable masters to ding iran a  great start for ding  with the black piece